(exciting instrumental music)
- We can never leave something on exhibit,
one particular item on
exhibit, for too long
because especially in clothing
there are certain dyes that
are very sensitive to light.
So even if it's on display
for a very brief time it could fade.
Sunlight is the most harmful, obviously.
I mean we know that the
sun dries things out,
makes them, fades them brittle;
think of autumn leaves.
But even artificial
lighting, again, over time
will have that cumulative
effect of fading,
and in some cases drying
out particular materials
like fiber and fabric.
In our galleries lighting
levels are as low as possible,
but high enough we hope so that visitors
can clearly see the detail.
You wonder, well why
can't that be on exhibit
for all the time because it
would be wonderful for visitors
to be able to see, and we agree with that,
because that's why people are coming here
to see the real thing.
But if you think of it
in the bigger picture
that even though the Kennedy presidency
was only 50 years ago,
and it's important to tell that story,
it's gonna be important to
tell it 100 years from now,
200 years from now, 300 years from now.